borås cover about 30% of the planet and
the ecosystems they create play an
essential role in supporting life on
Earth but deforestation is clearing
Earth's forests on a massive scale and
at the current rate of destruction the
world's rainforests could completely
disappear within a hundred years why
should we care about deforestation
together forestry and agriculture are
responsible for 24 percent of greenhouse
gas emissions making deforestation a
significant contributor to climate
change
deforestation impacts the amount of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere in
two ways first when trees are felled
they release the carbon they are storing
into the atmosphere second trees play a
critical role in absorbing the
greenhouse gases that fuel global
warming fewer forests mean larger
amounts of greenhouse gases entering the
atmosphere and increase speed and
severity of global warming in addition
to helping regulate the Earth's climate
forests provide habitats for over 80% of
the plants and animals that live on land
but deforestation destroys these
habitats diminishing biodiversity some
estimate that four to six thousand
rainforest species go extinct each year
this also affects the more than 2
billion people who rely on forests as
sources of food and shelter the biggest
driver of deforestation is agriculture
farmers chop down trees in order to
plant crops like soybeans palm trees in
cocoa or to make room to raise livestock
for beef logging operations which
provide the world's wood and paper
products also cut countless trees each
year forests are also destroyed as a
result of growing urban sprawl as land
is developed for dwellings the effects
of deforestation are grave but not
irreversible efforts such as managing
forest resources eliminating
clear-cutting
and planting new trees to replace those
removed are already being made to reduce
deforestation environmental impact on
our planet and while some plant and
animal species are gone forever
combating deforestation can help prevent
further loss of biodiversity
[Music]